and you're in the papers at the weekend
weren't you talking a lot about scotland
you've made some comparisons between the
snp
and nazis let me just remind our viewers
who may not have had a chance to
see the article some of the quotes what
are the points of comparison you say
well we have a political movement that
has a single historic explanation for
why your country is facing
such terrible oppression it's either
versailles or the treaty of union you
have a particular group of people who
are responsible for this
it is either the english or the jews
going on to say you have a symbol the
twisted cross the soul tire or the
swashticker
you have a passionate belief in economic
self-sufficiency known by the nazis as
otaki and the scots as oil and you also
have the propensity of your elderly and
middle-aged male supporters to expose
their knees
it's created a great deal of offence to
many people in scotland
are you sorry for the offence it's
caused
no of course not um we have this awful
idiotic pc politics
what we've got to recognize i said
nothing about scotland
i said a great deal about the snp the
snp
is a virulently nationalist party of a
type that we have not
had in britain it models itself on the
continental extreme nationalist
movements
of the 1930s that's when it's founded
it's time we call things
by their proper names that's all i'm
trying to do i'm not saying they're
about to set up concentration camps
i'm not going to say that we're going to
see a crystal nacht of english
businesses
in edinburgh of course we're not but the
resemblances
are striking and are worrying now we've
spent years
fussing in britain about completely
minor fringe things
like the bmp and whatever they are
nothing compared
with the scottish nationalist party
which has
seized control of the whole country and
is pushing
this kind of radical agenda they talk
about
civic nationalism the word civic is
merely a fig leaf or perhaps bearing in
mind that it's scotland
a jock strap you say you seize control
50
of the population voted for them
yes of course but so lots of people have
voted for very unpleasant
leaders i shall mention the word hitler
i mean the [ __ ]
sorry democracy it doesn't always get it
right
you but comparing the the saltire to the
swastika that's not the snp symbol of
saltire it's
symbol it's the flag of saint andrew i
do know these things
but it has been appropriated by the snp
in a very particular way look
i mean look at those scenes in glasgow
at the time of the independence vote
and listen again listen to the cybernets
if you disbelieve me